the former health secretary sajid chavi
there explaining his reasons for
resigning from the government last night
let's uh check in with our chief
political correspondent john craig in
central lobby there in the houses of
parliament and uh john were all trying
to work out what might be going on
behind me here in number 10.
well here in parliament i can tell you
that mps are aghast at the reports we're
hearing that the prime minister has told
his cabinet colleagues i'm not quitting
now i can tell you that that is indeed
the case because i've just been it's
just been reported to me uh that the
ministers who went in to see the prime
minister said to him you've got to go
prime minister and they said to him no i
am not going well they were aghast i
just been talking to one of the
ministers who resigned today she said no
but i can tell you i have it on very
good authority that the prime minister
from a senior mp
that the prime minister has told cabinet
colleagues he will not quit now to
assess that i am joined by uh the leader
westminster leader of the scottish
national party ian blackford what do you
make of the fact that pm's refusing to
go well knowing the character of the man
i suppose i'm not surprised but you know
we have to say to boris johnson he's not
a dictator
he's there in power because he's put in
by the
the public of course at the election but
he is only there with the confidence of
the mps that serve in this parliament it
doesn't have the confidence of his own
party he doesn't have the confidence of
his own cabinet if he had any decency
any self-respect any dignity he would
realize that for him this is over he
will be dragged out next week because
the tory party will make sure the 1922
committee changed the rules they can
have a motion of no confidence this is a
man that just about universally
parliament wants gone he cannot stay in
office but he needs to show some
self-sacrifice he needs to realise for
him he should have been gone by now and
to diggies heels in when his own cabinet
have turned against him my goodness this
is unprecedented
but he's been arguing today both at
prime minister's questions when you had
your usual weekly joust with him
and also upstairs at the liaison
committee
that
he's got a mandate he was elected in
2019 with a majority of 80. he claims
he's got a mandate from the public he's
broken the trust that was put into him
in that election campaign mps are acting
in the interest of their constituents
knowing that this man is now unpopular
to such an extent a man that we know
that has misled parliament has lied has
cheated he's lied again and put
ministers in impossible situations this
week for him it's over and for him to
try and cling on desperately to cling on
this simply won't work parliament will
do its job and the fact that he is
showing no dignity in his final hours in
his final days really speaks about the
content that this man has for parliament
this is not his personal plaything this
is a man let's not forget that illegally
shut down parliament the corrugation of
parliament once again he's trying to
cling on but quite frankly he's left
with very few friends in this place you
say parliament will have its say but the
fact is he's still even after a few
by-election defeats got a pretty big
majority
there's nothing you as opposition
parties can do is there let's wait and
see and i think first well i think first
and foremost what has to happen is
conservative mps have got to take their
own responsibility within their hands
they can do that through the 1922
committee now normally it would be the
case that a motion of no confidence
would have no chance of success because
tory mps would vote with the government
would vote with the prime minister this
is fracturing to such an extent that
there is that option if anyone else
fails that emotional confidence might be
the only way that we can get rid of this
prime minister but my message to tory
mps on monday they have got to do that
job they have got to make sure that they
pass a motion of no confidence to them
let's get this man that's besmir the
office of prime minister out the door if
he's not going to do it then he needs to
be dragged screaming and kicking out of
the door but i think i'm right here
saying that a motion of no confidence on
the floor of the house that motion has
to come from the leader of the official
opposition doesn't it it would have to
come from the leader of the official
opposition to be taken that's absolutely
correct but let's make sure tory mps
take their responsibilities next monday
when they have the 1922 committee and
then they make sure that there's a
motion of no confidence the house has to
speak with a very clear voice this man
has to go
your colleague from the flight comery
today in the comments said that he was
the uh the prime minister the current
prime minister was the best recruiting
sergeant for independence of i assume
she meant wales and scotland um
secretly
we all know that you and he get on quite
well across the commons chamber there
you probably want him to stay because
you think he's good for the cause of
independence probably i actually have no
relationship with the prime minister i
want him gone and we will win
independence on the basis of the appeal
that we put to the people in scotland
about how we deliver a greener economy
one that can deliver sustainable
economic growth and fairness we don't
need boris johnson to do that we will do
that but in the meantime this man is a
danger to democracy he has to be gone